[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
guten abend hinein genauso wichtig wie
das duell selbst ist das was direkt
danach kommt also jetzt manchmal ist es
noch wichtiger denn jetzt geht es um die
deutungshoheit wer hat sich wie
geschlagen wer hat gewonnen wer verloren
jetzt geht es darum den bleibenden
eindruck zu beeinflussen auch bei denen
die diskussion selbst womöglich gar
nicht geguckt haben und jetzt nur die
schlagzeilen lesen jetzt schlägt die
stunde der sogenannten spin doktoren die
für ihre jeweiligen kandidaten die sache
drehen sollen und all das passiert dann
im fernsehstudio in berlin adlershof wo
theo koll die situation beobachtet und
nahm theo wie sieht's aus bei dir dort
jedes lager von der eigenen kandidatin
kandidaten überzeugt oder lässt sich da
schon ein klares urteil ausmachen
also jedes lager sogar begeistert von
den eigenen kandidaten der eigene
kandidatin es gab hier zwischenzeitlich
immer wieder applaus man hatte sich im
prinzip aufgeteilt in drei verschiedene
lager hier im hintergrund familie ist im
wesentlichen die union die cdu vertreten
und sieht ministerpräsidenten minister
die hergekommen sind zur unterstützung
ihres kandidaten im zelt saßen links die
spd auch mit minister heil vertreten bei
den grünen frau göring-eckardt also die
generalsekretäre jeder hatte im grunde
unterstützung mitgebracht die dann auch
in den richtigen momenten natürlich ihre
kandidaten hier während des tri ace
feierten dann geht er noch mal so ein
bisschen in so eine kleine blitz analyse
wenn man so will was war der
überraschendste moment aus deiner sicht
jetzt in abgesehen davon von dem kleinen
technik versagen dass die uhr bei scholz
weiterlief und frau bär burg so
freundlich war darauf hinzuweisen dass
ihr konkurrent da benachteiligt wurde es
wurde ja dann korrigiert ich fand es
hochinteressant die redeschlacht die
sich rund um das finanzministerium und
die verantwortung des finanzministers
entwickelt hat denn da sahen wir dass
armin laschet angegriffen hat wie auch
schon beim ersten trial aber
gleichzeitig auch olaf scholz sich so
aggressiv verteidigt hat wie wir das
bisher nicht erlebt haben da ging es
darum
dass der vorwurf kam scholz habe die
staatsanwaltschaft kritisiert dafür dass
es dort eine razzia gab das habe die
glaubwürdigkeit der institution der
justiz unterwandert olaf scholz hat sich
dann massiv verteidigt das sei unredlich
frau baerbock ist mit eingestiegen hat
das thema geldwäsche es ging dabei um
die institution die für die geldwäsche
in deutschland zuständig ist deutschland
ist der notorisch schlecht sie wies
darauf hin dass wir 50 milliarden im
jahr verlieren weil wir da so schlecht
aufgestellt sind also das war eine sehr
hitzige und untypische debatte für diese
trio wenn wir noch einmal kurz auf die
gesamtsituation gucken unter besonderer
beobachtung auch der eigenen leute stand
ja heute abend armin laschet er durfte
sich keinen patzer erlauben wie hat er
das gemeistert
alle alle drei haben das gut gemeistert
also der größte druck war natürlich auf
armin laschet nicht nur weil er hinter
olaf scholz deutlich zurück liegt
sondern auch weil seine eigenen
parteifreunde der schwesterpartei csu ja
die messlatte sehr hoch gelegt hatten
markus söder hatte gesagt das ist das
wochenende im grunde der entscheidung
also jetzt ist das wochenende wo man
noch eine wende herbeiführen gerne
insofern werden sicherlich der druck auf
armin laschet besonders groß aber nach
meiner wahrnehmung haben alle drei sich
da wirklich gut geschlagen jeder hat
seine position klargemacht zu coroner zu
klima zu finanzen zur zukunft der
nächsten bundesregierung theo koll
herzlichen dank nach berlin für den
moment du hast es gab schon gesagt hier
oder csu chef markus söder die mir ein
feines näschen für stimmungen nachgesagt
wird er sagte an diesem wochenende wird
sich alles entscheidenden zitat wenn es
noch eine chance gibt den trend zu
brechen dann an diesem wochenende und da
hatte er natürlich den laschen auftritt
auf seinem eigenen csu-parteitag im
blick aber vor allem dieses trio wir
sind also gespannt was die umfragedaten
dazu hergeben aber erst matthias fornoff
der fairness halber bevor wir jetzt auf
die zahlen gucken wie valide sind die
denn wie valide können die seien jetzt
so kurz nach der sendung
guten abend die zahlen die die
forschungsgruppe wahlen da bis vor
wenigen minuten für uns erhoben hat die
sind repräsentativ und zwar für die
wahlberechtigten zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer der sendung nicht für alle
wahlberechtigten in deutschland
logischerweise da die fragen sich ja auf
den fernseh dreikampf beziehen und wer
es nicht gesehen hat kann es auch nicht
beurteilen
die zahlen die wir jetzt zeigen sie
beziehen sich auf die erste hälfte also
etwa die ersten 45 minuten des tv tri
ace und dann gucken doch matthias wir
haben die drei auf dieser basis die du
grad genannt hast abgeschnitten ja die
spannende frage war natürlich wer hat
hier am besten abgeschnitten und das
schauen wir mal auf die erste grafik und
seen armin laschet sagen 16 prozent wer
hat sich am besten geschlagen olaf
scholz 34 prozent annalena baerbock 26
prozent und 22 prozent sehen da keinen
großen unterschied dass wir gesagt ist
die zwischenbilanz nach etwa einer
dreiviertelstunde
scholz vor baerbock vor laschet und wir
schauen jetzt noch mal nicht im
vergleich seiner auf jeden einzelnen und
da sehen wir in der nächsten grafik dass
die erwartungen erfüllt hat oder sogar
besser war armin laschet sagen 27
prozent aber das interessante ist wenn
wir mal alle drei balken hochfahren hier
das sehen wir bei armin laschet und bei
olaf scholz dass der blaue balken die
waren ungefähr so wie wir es erwartet
haben mit 57 und 59 prozent mehrheiten
deutlich am höchsten ist bei annalena
baerbock ist auffällig dass 44 prozent
gesehen haben dass sie besser
abgeschnitten hat als man erwartet hatte
und die gute nachricht für alle drei ist
das kaum einer wirklich schlechter
abgeschnitten hat das sagen nur sagt nur
eine minderheit und jetzt schauen wir
noch mal als letztes auf die profile der
3 denn daraus kann man auch immer ein
bisschen hinweise er sehen woran es ist
dein liegt wohl wie diese zahlen
zustande gekommen sind wer war am
glaubwürdigsten scholz und bernburg
dicht beieinander armin laschet ziemlich
abgeschlagen wer war am sympathischsten
da sehen wir olaf scholz vorne für
annalena baerbock armin laschet auch da
weit hinten und wird zeigte am meisten
sachverstand das ist ein eindeutiges
bild bei dieser halbzeitbilanz
45 prozent sagen olaf scholz hatte am
meisten sachverstand gezeigt
und während wir reden laufen die
telefone weiter heißt es gibt weitere
befragungen hunderte der
forschungsgruppe wein und am ende der
sendung haben wir dann enddaten für die
zuschauerinnen zuschauer die das ganze
tv trial gesehen haben so ist es möglich
dass vor vielen dank erstmal für diese
halbzeitbilanz im moment so erst haben
wir jetzt karl hinterleitner und
patricia wiedemeier und die wichtigsten
momente des abends in viereinhalb
minuten
schon stunden vor beginn des tri ace
musik jubel und stimmungsmache cdu spd
und grüne sie alle hatten ihre fans in
berlin vor dem fernsehstudio in
adlershof
schafft armin laschet die wende hält
olaf scholz den vorsprung in den
umfragen
findet annalena baerbock zu alter stärke
zurück die erwartungen hoch der druck
enorm für alle drei erstes thema wer
will mit wem regieren eine koalition mit
der fdp schließen alle aus mit der
linken jedoch nur die cdu eine
definitiven absage an rot-rot-grün gibt
es weder von scholz noch von baerbock
aber
wir koalieren mit der linken in einigen
bundesländern auch deswegen hat
selbstverständlich ist eine
demokratische partei aber wir haben in
der außenpolitik wir haben auch mit
blick auf die innenpolitik innere
sicherheit verfassungsschutz große
differenzen auch mit der linken das ist
klar wer in deutschland regieren will
muss klare positionen haben er muss sich
bekennen zur transatlantischen
zusammenarbeit da muss klar sagen dass
die nato für unsere sicherheit
unverzichtbar ist und dass wir unsere
verpflichtungen im bündnis erfüllen
müssen da muss sich klar zu einer
starken souverän europäischen union
bekennen deshalb muss jedem klar sein
wenn es eine rechnerische mehrheit gibt
selbst wenn sie auf platz zwei liegen
als partei werden sie eine koalition mit
den linken machen dass deshalb glauben
die bürgerinnen und bürger ihnen das nur
wenn sie klipp und klar sagen
jemand der den verfassungsschutz
abschaffen will erst der nato raus will
selbst wenn der nachher auf einem papier
zugestehen würde ja ich bin vielleicht
doch für eine reformierte nato sie
müssen klarheit haben zweites thema
steuern und finanzen vor allem bei
comics wirecard und der razzia im
bundesfinanzministerium habe schuld
seiner aufsichtspflichten nicht
wahrgenommen
es ist schon ein wunder wie sie selbst
in diesem fall wenn eine
staatsanwaltschaft in ihr ministerium
kommt und untersuchungen durchführt eine
solche schönrederei an den tag legen
können wenn mein finanzminister so aber
würde wie sie hätten wir ein ernstes
problem
er hat kein im hause war die stadt denn
ist doch runter drehen die
staatsanwaltschaft hat eine untersuchung
in köln und für die untersuchung die sie
dort macht braucht sie auskünfte sie hat
keine untersuchung dem hinblick auf
dieses ministerium und weil sie das so
darstellen erwecken sie einen falschen
eindruck packen völlig beiseite dass der
größte modernisierungs und aufbauprozess
dieser behörde stattgefunden knapp drei
jahren in denen ich minister bin und
packen noch ein paar andere unwahrheiten
dazu wenn uns 50 milliarden jährlich als
staat verloren gehen durch geldwäsche
man muss sich das mal überlegen das
organisierte kriminalität dass es
drogenhandel das ist mafia wird es von
ihrer bundesregierung beziehungsweise
das ist das was ich möchte wenn wir die
bundesregierung anführen als grüne nicht
mehr möglich sein das war mit bargeld im
großen großem maßstab immobilien und
häuser kaufen kann weil da wird das
ganze geld in deutschland gewaschen
nächstes thema krone was ist die
zentrale lehre aus der pandemie dass wir
wegen einem stück maske für wenige cent
irgendwo in der welt produziert wochen
lang einen gesundheitsschutz hatte und
die horrende summen auf den weltmärkten
bezahlt darf nie wieder passieren ein
krisenstab damit es eine politische
verantwortung hergibt wir müssen den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst in
deutschland auf den modernsten stand
bringen da dürfen wir nicht mit aufhören
bliebe noch der klimaschutz versprechen
gibt es von allen dreien wir können
nicht 17 jahre lang weiter so machen als
wäre nichts passiert deswegen ist für
mich klar die nächste bundesregierung
muss den kohleausstieg vorziehen auf
2.030 wann fangen sie an den menschen zu
sagen dass sich ihr leben verteuern wird
wenn sie zu viel co2 ausstoßen naja wir
sagen vor allem den menschen ihr leben
besser wird wenn sie klimaneutral leben
wir wollen einen moderaten weg gehen und
es ist auch richtig dass wir sagen wir
wollen in dieser frage das geld den
bürgern und bürgern zurückgeben indem
wir dafür sorgen dass der strom billiger
wird anderthalb stunden triest waren
viele themen viele bekannte argumente es
bleibt dennoch spannend noch sind es 14
tage bis zur wahl
da diskutieren 3d ins kanzleramt wollen
aber klar ist natürlich allein wird es
niemand von ihnen schafften nach der
wahl ist die kunst gefragt auf der basis
des ergebnisses und der politischen
überzeugungen eine koalition zu bilden
aller voraussicht nach einer mit gleich
drei parteien und damit kommt die fdp
ins spiel wolfgang kubicki ist der
stellvertretende parteichef guten am tag
uwg grüne nannte sie jetzt müssen wir
kubicki natürlich ganz stark in unseren
hinterköpfen behalten dass sie sich
vielleicht mal abgesehen von christian
lindner niemanden so sehr im kanzleramt
wünschen wie armin laschet trotzdem die
frage wer hat sie heute am meisten
überzeugt
ja zunächst einmal es ist schwer für
mich der politische mitbewerber wenn wir
den drei und jetzt eine vergleichsweise
objektive bewertung abzugeben ist müssen
sie danach sehe es wäre ja auch nicht
die kandidaten gewesen die parteien
darunter auch die freien demokraten
versuchen sie mal herr kubicki mich hat
überrascht dass du dich sagen mich hat
überrascht dass olaf scholz dünnhäutig
bei den erwartbaren angriffen von armin
laschet
die behauptung er habe seine
aufsichtspflicht verletzt sie stand ja
schon vorher im auge hat armin laschet
ja schon auf dem parteitag der csu
erhoben darauf hätte man noch souveräner
reagieren können und ansonsten war alles
was im trial gesagt war es für mich
natürlich keine überraschung weil das
überall schon mal gesagt worden ist ja
alles auf einen punkt ja mir ist
aufgefallen entgegen der auffassung der
zuschauerinnen zuschauer das annalena
baerbock eigentlich zwischen den beiden
schwergewichten doch eine
vergleichsweise leichte rolle gespielt
hat aber ihre aussage eine regierung
unter beteiligung der grünen müssen bis
20.30 aus der kohle komplett aussteigen
aus der verstromung von gas und kohle
ihr so absurd weil er bis dahin die
müsst ihr erklären wo der strom
herkommen soll bis dahin gar nicht so
viel kapazitäten aufbauen können um das
zu letzten meiningen ist hängt an den
meisten kohlekraftwerken auch die zahl
der versorgung etwas was mir bei meinem
neuen hausbau jetzt auch gerade
geschehen ist das mit fernwärme versorgt
wurde auch das muss er innerhalb von
kurzer zeit der umstrukturierung aber
ansonsten wie gesagt herr kubicki hat
sich nicht gerne überrascht da muss ich
gleich mal kurz rein jetzt haben sich
die grünen angegriffen vor baerbock das
sieht doch eher so aus dass egal wie es
am ende ausgeht sie sich daran gewöhnen
werden müssen mit den grünen
möglicherweise eine koalition bilden zu
müssen und zwar als juniorpartner
verglichen mit den grünen das schauen
wir mal das ergebnis steht noch nicht
fest trotz der netten umfragen die da
sind bei der letzten umfrage liegen wir
zwei punkte auseinander das ist alles
noch machbar unabhängig davon ich komme
aus einer funktionierenden michael zorc
stand ich habe mich mit robert habe
gemeinsam ein koalitionsvertrag
ausgehandelt der bis heute hält die
regierung für deutschland ist
einigermaßen stabil und wird auch von
der bevölkerung anerkannt also es ist
möglich und ich habe auch zwar eine
leichte präferenz zu armin laschet aber
ich kenne olaf scholz auch aus der
norddeutschen tagen sehr gut auch mit
ihm kann man vernünftig reden und
insofern warten wir das ergebnis ab und
da schauen wir was dabei rauskommt und
ich sage noch einmal entscheidend ist
dass in deutschland wirklich was
passiert wenn ich wieder die letzten
jahre nur über die probleme reden ohne
sie zu lösen die taktik bei ihnen beim
umworbenen möglichen koalitionspartner
fdp muss natürlich lauten sich so teuer
wie möglich verkaufen alle optionen
waren pokern können sie programm herr
kubicki nein ich hier kann nicht pokern
aber ich habe schon fünf mal in meinem
leben koalitionsverträge verhandelt er
sieht was ist schön da sie wissen was
wir strategisch uns zu überlegen müssen
wir warten das wahlergebnis ab und dann
schauen wir sie haben eine präferenz für
jamaika selbstverständlich gar keine
frage wir haben ein sehr gutes
vertrauensverhältnis asche in nordrhein
westfalen wie ihr selbst mit den grünen
gemeinsam in schleswig holstein und der
union ja aber noch einmal wir haben auch
eine gute geschichte mit die
sozialdemokraten in der vergangenheit es
gebe ohne spd und fdp ist keine ost
politik das ist das was ich einiges
vorwerfen muss die sozialdemokratische
schon mal auf der richtigen seite der
geschichte und die union auf der
falschen seite ich selbst war an dem
prozess beteiligt sind vertreter von
unionsleuten verspottet worden also
meine so sollte vielleicht abrüsten bis
zum wahltag wissen und sich darauf
konzentrieren die probleme der zukunft
zu lösen jetzt bin ich nicht ich der der
strategische in koalitions- ideen denkt
sondern ihr eigener parteichef christian
lindner der hatte einen bemerkenswerten
auftritt im deutschen bundestag und hat
dem in umfragen führenden spd mann stolz
entgegen gerufen es muss nicht immer der
mit den meisten stimmen auch kanzler
werden ist denn vorstellbar dass armin
laschet selbst wenn er krachend
verlieren sollte am ende dann doch
irgendwie eine koalition zimmern könnte
ist das für sie vorstellbar denkbar
schon die frage ist wie wahrscheinlich
ist dass wir hatten ja der deutsche
geschichte schon zweimal einen solchen
vorgang willy brandt während
bundeskanzler geworden aus der 69 weil
es keine mehrheit für die spd gab tag
die union vorne trotzdem habe ich freien
demokraten mit der spd eine
sozialliberale koalition begründet und
1976 war helmut kultur zwei absolute
mehrheit es trotzdem nicht kanzler
geworden weil wir als freie demokraten
die koalition mit spd der ist mir die
fortgesetzt haben also es gibt auch
andere denkbare
möglichkeiten aber es hängt dann
tatsächlich vom spread die
wahrscheinlichkeit glaube ich ist nicht
sehr groß dass wenn die union dramatisch
hinter den sozialen sind demokraten
liegt ist eine realistische chance gibt
eine andere position zu bilden vor
einigen weil ich nicht glaube dass die
grünen das überhaupt leisten könnten ok
haben wir verstanden wird von kubicki
von der fdp der stellvertretende
parteichef danken für das gespräch und
die linkspartei hat ihre karten bereits
auf dem tisch gelegt kann man so sagen
und umarmt die spd gerade sehr offen und
mit ganzem herzen wir stehen bereit für
rot grün rot janine wissler ist die
spitzenkandidatin der linken frau
wissler wer ist ihr sieger erst mal
schönen guten abend nach berlin wer ist
ihr sieger heute abend
ich werde keinen der drei wählen ich
fand ein paar sachen doch etwas
überraschend in der debatte dass zum
beispiel mehr über die kosten für
klimaschutz gesprochen wurde als über
die kosten des klimawandels obwohl ja
gerade auch in diesem sommer gesehen
haben wie verheerend die folgen des
klimawandels sind also da fand ich
insbesondere
von herrn scholz und herren laschet die
aussagen wirklich total an der
oberfläche und einfach zu hoffen dass
von selber was passiert das wird sich ja
so nicht sein ich fand beim thema wohnen
alle drei ziemlich schwach weil es hat
sich niemand eine klare grenze und
mieten deckel und dazu dass wir mehr
wohnungen in der öffentlichen hand
brauchen dass der immobilienspekulation
bekämpfen müssen also von daher gibt es
gute gründe warum wir antreten als
partei- und viele punkte die nur bei uns
zu finden sind jetzt fiel auf dass olaf
scholz beim tri l fiel mir zumindest
hoffen dass den namen ihrer partei die
linke kaum in den mund genommen hat er
sprach einmal von die partei die sie
gerade genannt haben bezogen auf die
moderatoren wie www hat ihnen das getan
es ist mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
aufgefallen ich war froh dass annalena
baerbock mal deutlich gemacht hat dass
diese gefährliche gleichsetzung zwischen
rechts und links dass das aufhören muss
und ich finde gerade eben vor den im
angesicht der gefahr von rechts die wir
erleben hannah hanna der mord an walter
lübke die nsu wurde dass diese
gleichsetzung unsäglich ist das was sie
ansprechen ist mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht aufgefallen aber ja olaf scholz
hat klare bedingungen gestellt um
überhaupt die linken in erwägung zu
ziehen für eine koalition bekenntnis zur
nato steht immer ganz oben auch jetzt
gerade in dem was wir heute abend gehört
haben im trie l wäre jetzt der richtige
moment nicht um dieses bekenntnis
abzulegen von ihnen ich glaube es hilft
nicht viel voneinander bekenntnisse zu
verlangen erstens wenn ich der meinung
uns bedroht doch gerade kein
ausländischer staat uns bedroht der
klimawandel uns bedroht eine weltweite
pandemie und viel lieber würde ich
darüber reden was das denn praktisch
heißen soll nämlich dass zwei prozent
ziel der nato weitere aufrüstung 25
milliarden mehr für die rüstung das
lehnen wir ab wir lehnen
waffenlieferungen ab an dem nato partner
türkei die aus der bundesregierung
weiter erfolgen über solche dinge können
wir gerne reden aber gar islam haben wir
gerade das desaster schlag das problem
natürlich müssen wir über den
klimawandel reden über die klimakrise
reden ist doch vollkommen klar tun wir
ja auch sehr sehr häufig trotzdem haben
wir im moment die situation dass da
jemand in den umfragen führt und kanzler
werden will und sagt er braucht ein
bekenntnis zur nato um überhaupt mit der
linken zusammengehen zu können das nur
zu überlegen überhaupt und auf der
anderen seite steht in ihrem
wahlprogramm sie fordern die auflösung
der nato
das passt ja nicht zusammen da muss sich
ja einer in irgendeiner form bewegen
werden sie das am ende sein
ja das ist richtig dass wir da sehr
unterschiedliche auffassungen haben und
ich finde wir haben ja gerade gesehen
das scheitern der nato in afghanistan
und ich bin eigentlich der meinung dass
jetzt mal die parteien die die
bundeswehr dorthin geschickt haben in
diesen auslandseinsatz nochmal
reflektieren sollten ob es eine richtige
entscheidung war wir sind der meinung
dass es nicht so war aber schauen sie
sich meine egal welche parteien
miteinander koalieren es gibt immer
differenzen die überwunden werden müssen
das hat sich ja heute abend auch ganz
klar gezeigt kubicki hat gerade gesagt
kohleausstieg zwar 38 mit der fdp nicht
zu machen also es gibt noch zwischen
allen parteien differenzen sonst werden
wir ja nicht verschiedene parteien und
am ende stellt sich die frage sind die
differenzen zur union und zu fdp
leichter zu überbrücken als zu uns oder
kann man mit uns er die politik machen
die die spd gerade auf ihre
wahlprogramme schreib oder auf ihre
wahlplakate schreibt und ich lese da
höherer mindestlohn ich lese da gute
rente ich lese da mehr bezahlbaren
wohnraum und da sind auch große
übereinstimmungen da aber ja an vielen
stellen haben wir dort differenzen und
das ist vollkommen klar und wir wollen
eine politik von abrüstung wir wollen
waffenexporte stoppen und wir wollen
keine kriegseinsätze weil wir gerade
gesehen haben dass krieg eben nicht zu
frieden und sicherheit führt sagt janine
wissler die spitzenkandidatin der
linkspartei frau wissler vielen dank für
das gespräch heute abend ich danke ihm
ja koalitions sorgen hat team europa
spitzenkandidat der afd nicht ob alle
guten abend schön
abend hallo asi was mal abgesehen davon
dass keine einzige der anderen parteien
mit ihnen koalieren will mit wem könnten
sie es sich denn nach dem heutigen abend
am ehesten vorstellen
nun ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen die
erste dreiviertelstunde dieses
sogenannten trials weichen stück weit
entsetzt weil dort haben die zwei
parteien im prinzip duelliert die cdu
und die spd die eigentlich seit acht
jahren regiert haben und haben sich ihre
unfähigkeit gegenseitig vorgeworfen das
hat mich überrascht über die wirklichen
wirklichen probleme der deutschen hat
man kaum gesprochen man hat auch wenig
angesprochen zum beispiel die themen
renten auch wenig die steuerproblematik
die steuerreform die wir dringend
brauchen in diesem land auch die
inflation wurde zum beispiel mit keinem
wort erwähnt also für uns sind alle drei
parteien aktuell auch nicht
koalitionsfähig mit uns das muss man
ganz klar sagen weil die wirklichen
sorgen und probleme des mittelstands der
mittelschicht aber der bürger in
deutschland wurden nicht angesprochen
haben die landschaft hat gesagt ich will
dass die hfg aus den parlamenten
verschwindet
ja das ist das ist eine meinung aber
arbeit leistet wird das nicht
entscheiden das entscheiden die bürger
und das entscheiden die wähler auch
armin artet entscheidet nicht mehr
demokratisch ist und wir nicht
demokratisch ist also das fand ich so
oft bemerkenswert dass über die afg sehr
viel geredet wurde obwohl sie gar nicht
zugegen war das wären die wähler
entscheiden und ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass die wähler sehr wohl
entscheiden werden dass die afg eine
demokratische partei ist wir haben das
in der vergangenheit bewiesen wir haben
als einzige korrektiv im parlament im
bundestag die letzten vier jahre ohne
uns gäbe es in vielen bereichen
überhaupt keinen fortschritten auch
keine elf einigen bekanntmachung in
vielen dingen die auf die probleme in
diesem land hingewiesen haben also das
haben wir schon gut gemacht und das
werden wir die nächsten vier jahre auch
tun herr grupp aller wenn von vornherein
klar ist die eigene partei wird nicht in
der regierung landen und das ist ja bei
ihnen klar ist dann ein wahlkampf
eigentlich schwieriger weil es kein
wirkliches ziel gibt oder leichter weil
sie im grunde genommen sagen können was
sie wollen
was heißt sagen können dass wir wollen
unser parteiprogramm ist am gesunden
menschenverstand orientiert vor allen
dingen ehrlich wir haben keine fantasien
was den klimawandel angeht was wir von
allen reihen parteien gehört haben wir
wollen kein vorzeitiger kohleausstieg
auch der kohleausstieg 38 halte ich für
überambitioniert wird vor allen dingen
was die netzlast lichkeit was die
stromversorgung als die strom sicherheit
und was die kosten vor allen dingen an
geht über die wurde ja ein bisschen
gesprochen aber nicht viel die frage wer
das alles bezahlen soll das stellen wir
diese fragen stellen wie er und ihnen
haben in diesem so genannten träger kaum
auf und das ist genau richtig dass es
diese opposition diese partei auf die
für uns gibt für deutschland gibt und
das wenn die bürger am 26 auch wissen
manchmal hat man allerdings den eindruck
die afg macht lieber wahlkampf gegen
sich selbst beim landesparteitag der fdp
in baden württemberg nannte frau weil
ihre parteifreunde gerade maulhelden und
sagte dann ich glaub ich spinne hier
haben sie verständnis dafür wenn das
manche wähler auch denken
wir sind sehr innerparteiliche
differenzen gibt es in allen parteien
sie haben doch die diskussion zwischen
herrschenden vermaßen gehört also ich
fand das ganz interessant oder zwischen
palma und frau berbalk also dass jetzt
der afg nur zuzuschieben ich bin ich ein
bisschen eigenartig das gibt es überall
das klären wir intern und ich denke frau
pop idol hat auch in baden württemberg
mehr richtigen ton getroffen der
parteitag störungsfrei ab da etwas
hineinzuinterpretieren halte ich für ein
bisschen merkwürdig gut also
störungsfrei ab das kann man sich ja im
netz noch mal angucken was alles dort
passiert ist er hob aber ich denke auf
jeden fall ganz herzlich für das
gespräch heute abend
sehr gern schöne art danke ihnen schönen
abend und weitere wichtige nachrichten
jetzt rund um die welt an diesem sonntag
von gundula zum auftakt der aktionswoche
für corona impfungen mehren sich die
appelle aus der politik sich impfen zu
lassen bundeskanzlerin merkel sagte nie
sei es einfacher gewesen eine impfung zu
bekommen angesichts des schleppenden im
fortschritts fürchten mediziner volle
intensivstationen in den nächsten
monaten die aktuellen zahlen am
wochenende wegen fehlender meldungen
allerdings immer etwas niedriger laut
lka
7345 neuinfektionen
3108 weniger als vergangenen sonntag
auch die sieben tage incidents sinkt auf
jetzt 80,2
etwas bewegung ist offenbar in den
festgefahrenen atomstreit mit iran
gekommen die internationale
atomenergiebehörde soll wieder zugang zu
ihren videokameras in den iranischen
atomanlagen erhalten die geräte können
wieder gewartet und mit neuen
speicherkarten ausgestattet werden
bisherige aufzeichnungen hält teheran
aber weiter zurück aus protest gegen us
sanktionen
papst franziskus hat bei seinem
kurzbesuch in ungarn kritik an der
regierung und an der ungarischen
bevölkerung geübt vor rund 100.000
gläubigen rief er zu offenheit und
respekt auf über inhalte des gesprächs
mit ungarns ministerpräsident orban
wurde nichts veröffentlicht bekannt ist
aber dass der papst immer wieder hilfe
für flüchtlinge fordert und orban
dagegen auf eine anti migrationspolitik
setzt bis mittwoch ist der papst in der
slowakei um sich auch dort für die
christlichen wurzeln europas einzusetzen
es geht schritt für schritt aber die
richtung ist klar in der neuen taliban
übergangsregierung sitzt keine einzige
frau dafür diverse islamisten die auch
unter der letzten schreckensherrschaft
in afghanistan an der macht waren ein
gruselkabinett an den universitäten wird
es künftig nur noch unterricht nach
geschlechtern getrennt geben und mit
strengen kleidungsvorschriften und
demonstrationen gegen die taliban sind
verboten der protest gerade der von
frauen wird dadurch umso mutiger und
umso gefährlicher katrin eigendorf ist
in kabul
in einem restaurant im zentrum von kabul
haben sich frauen versammelt die
widerstand gegen die taliban leisten
wollen seitdem ihre letzte
protestkundgebung von den islamisten
brutal niedergeschlagen wurde
debattieren sie nun darüber wie es
weitergeht
wir müssen vorsichtig sein unser eigenes
leben schützen und auch dass unsere
freunde wir sollten uns nicht irgendwo
draußen treffen
bis vor einigen wochen kannten sie sich
noch nicht jetzt nennen sie sich
widerstandsbewegung der afghanischen
frauen sie haben ein netzwerk das über
das ganze land reicht wir sollen ihre
gesichter zeigen sagen sie weil es zu
riskant ist im restaurant ein interview
zu führen der besitzer könnte uns bei
den taliban melden beschließen wir zu
mariam nach hause zu fahren als deutsche
journalistin brauche ich die genehmigung
der taliban in afghanistan drehen zu
können auch ich möchte nicht zu viel
aufmerksamkeit erregen die taliban haben
überall in kabul ihre kämpfer postiert
inzwischen auch mitglied der ira
spezialeinheiten an denen wir
vorbeifahren seitdem die islamisten die
macht übernommen sind nur wenige frauen
unterwegs warum wagen sie was viele
männer sich nicht trauen den islamisten
die stirn zu bieten
es sind vor allem die rechte der frauen
die jetzt mit füßen getreten werden
deswegen protestieren vor allem frauen
zu hause zeigt mariam die bilder der
letzten proteste mit tränengas und
schüssen in die luft wurden sie
vertrieben ihre freundin wurde dabei
verletzt mariam hat daraufhin eine
videobotschaft veröffentlicht
liebe landsleute die taliban haben bei
unseren protesten viele frauen
festgenommen sollten sie ermordet werden
oder verschwinden dann sind die taliban
dafür verantwortlich riskieren sie nicht
ihr leben möchte ich wissen
alle mädchen aber auch alle jungen
afghanistans hatten früher pläne
hoffnungen eine zukunft du kannst dir
sicher vorstellen wenn ein mensch all
seine hoffnungen und pläne verliert dann
spielt die sorge um dein leben keine
rolle
marias mutter sieht das auch so
ich unterstütze sie und ich werde sie
nicht abhalten ich habe keine gute
erinnerung an die taliban 18 monate
waren wir eingesperrt zu hause wir
hatten keinen job und auch kein
einkommen mehr
beim abschied bitten mariam und ihrer
mutter wir müssten berichten was mit den
frauen afghanistans passiert die
internationale aufmerksamkeit sei jetzt
ihre wichtigste hoffnung
afghanistan lässt auch die mächtigen in
den hauptstädten der welt nicht mehr
ruhig schlafen denn wenn eine großmacht
scheitert und abzieht dann stellt sich
sofort die frage wer folgt so ein
machtvakuum bleibt nicht lange ungefüllt
china der nachbar mit weltweiten
großmacht ambitionen steht bereit die
staatsmedien schlachten das nato
versagen in afghanistan genüsslich aus
und china verspricht den taliban eine
lohnende zusammenarbeit tatsächlich aber
handelt die regierung in peking wohl
weniger als wirtschaftlicher wohltäter
sondern eher aus sorge vor chaos an der
westgrenze wie stephanie schöneborn
zeigt
wenn im chinesischen staatsfernsehen
über afghanistan berichtet wird dann
fühlt es sich manchmal so an als sei das
chinesische afghanistan ein anderes als
dass vom rest der welt kaum ein land
konnte in den letzten tagen und wochen
scheinbar so problemlos über afghanistan
und die übernahme der taliban berichten
wie china der kuschelkurs mit den
taliban zeigt sich auch daran wie
bereitwillig und offen mit chinesischen
medien gesprochen wird hochrangige
taliban sind voll des lobes und buhlen
um china als großen investitionspartner
wir hoffen insbesondere mit china gute
beziehungen zu entwickeln die auf
gegenseitigkeit und gemeinsam nutzen
worum
wir nehmen kontakt zu einem chinesischen
geschäftsmann auf der seit 20 jahren in
kabul lebt und arbeitet er zeigt uns ein
video aus china town in kabul seien
business ist stahl und zement sein
geschäftsansatz geprägt vom chinesischen
pragmatismus
uns ist es egal wer an der regierung ist
wir haben mit politik nichts zu tun sind
die geschäftsbedingungen gut machen wir
gewinnen läuft es nicht gut dann machen
wir eben keine gewinne
das bündnis zwischen china und den
taliban wurde schon vor abzug der
amerikaner in szene gesetzt respektvoll
empfängt der chinesische außenminister
den stellvertretenden taliban führer im
chinesischen tianjin china hat
wirtschaftliche interessen die
bodenschätze das seinen straßenprojekt
doch vor allem ist chinas größter angst
dass terror und gewalt nach china
übergreifen könnte mit einer
regierungsübernahme der taliban
afghanistan darf nie wieder der sichere
hafen des terrorismus werden das ist die
grundvoraussetzung für jedes politische
vorgehen zur lösung der probleme im land
china hat insgesamt natürlich große
sorgen um die sicherheitslage und die
stabilität und es nicht zu erwarten dass
china große summen in afghanistan
investieren wird solange diese
sicherheit nicht gewährleistet ist und
auf einmal ist der chinesische
geschäftsmann in kabul ein gradmesser
für die beziehungen zwischen china und
den taliban die bieten ihm sogar
sicherheitsschutz für sein china town in
kabul an
die taliban brauchen unsere projekte
sehr dringend alle unsere
handelsverträge wurden von den taliban
respektiert und sie wollen uns auch
weiter unterstützen
chinas pragmatismus
es wird zynisch wenn peking mit den
taliban freundschaft schließt und im
eigenen land menschen die den koran
lesen als extremisten gelten
und jetzt bei unserer sendung
großbritannien steht kopf die queen
inklusive denn es gibt eine echte tennis
sensation und sie ist 18 jahre alt
mehr
radu cana hat die us open gewonnen
großbritannien feiert seine erste grand
slam siegerin seit 44 jahren da gingen
sogar glückwunschschreiben von der queen
und prämien johnson im jubel zunächst
unter als sich die beiden teenager nach
dem finale umarmen sind respekt und
anerkennung groß beide haben bei den us
open außergewöhnliches geleistet
ich glaube das level in diesem finale
war sehr hoch und ich hoffe dass wir uns
noch bei vielen turnieren und vor allem
endspielen wiedersehen in diesem
hochklassigen finale erklärt die britin
raducanu etwas wuchtiger etwas
entschlossener
sie gewinnt den ersten satz nach einer
knappen stunde
emma hat so toll gespielt ich gratuliere
ihr und ihrem team aber ich bin auch
sehr stolz auf mich wie ich die letzten
beiden wochen gespielt habe ein ass von
raducanu beendet die partie 6 zu 4 und 6
3 vor drei monaten ist sie noch zur
schule gegangen jetzt kannte sich über
ein preisgeld von 2,5 millionen us
dollar freuen
drei spiele gab es in der fußball
bundesliga borussia mönchengladbach
gewann am abend gegen bielefeld 3 zu 1
zuvor hatte bochum gegen hertha bsc 1 zu
3 verloren es ist der erste saisonsieg
für die berliner und im dritten
sonntagsspiel zwischen eintracht
frankfurt und dem vfb stuttgart stand
ist zum schluss 1 zu 1 unentschieden in
der formel 1 gab es einen doppelerfolg
für mclaren der australier daniel
ricciardo siegte vorländer norris beim
großen preis von italien
die beiden wm rivalen max verstappen und
lewis hamilton
die in der 26 runde nach einer
spektakulären kollision aus dabei wurde
das buttons red bull über hamiltons
mercedes katapultiert beide fahrer
blieben unverletzt
sebastian vettel m s martin wurde
zwölfter
[Musik]
wir haben schon viel darüber gesprochen
heute abend was dieser moment im
wahlkampf bedeutet wie viel das tri l
jetzt tatsächlich entscheiden könnte
wirklich sicher wissen wir dass erst
natürlich am 26 september aber was immer
hilft ist der blick zurück ins archiv
auf zeiten in denen solche
fernsehdiskussionen in deutschland noch
ganz neu waren christian hübscher
das allererste tv duell in deutschland
überhaupt es ist 2002 es ist schröder
gegen stoiber eine münze entscheidet
darüber wer das erste wort hat stoiber
béla anda damals schröders
regierungssprecher erinnert sich noch
gut wie siegesgewiss sein chef in den
ring stieg das erste duell war stark
geprägt von dem eindruck dass gerd
schröder gewinnen müsste weil der
fernseher erfahren tekin und
bundeskanzler war gewann hat dieses
duell aber edmund stoiber weil er sehr
gut vorbereitet war 13 0 für stöger
bestäuber war für seine verhältnisse mit
schlecht auch die fernsehzuschauer sehen
stoiber damals knapp vorn hat sich
insgesamt besser geschlagen sagen 35
prozent schröder und 37% stoiber nur
zwei wochen später folgt ein weiteres
duell dass schröder diesmal für sich
entscheidet der bundeskanzler hat ja das
große versprechen abgegeben dass die
arbeitslosigkeit nach ende seiner ersten
amtszeit unter 3 5 millionen liegen wird
dieses versprechen ist massiv gebrochen
worden wir haben in 2001 400.000
arbeitslose weniger gehabt als 1998 die
spd wird die wahl danach gewinnen
schröder bundeskanzler bleiben
2005 tritt angela merkel zum ersten mal
ins tv duell ein format mit dem sie von
anfang an fremde und ich habe die cdu
auf einen modernisierungskurs geführt
der uns fit macht für das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert bitte um
vertrauen für eine politik die ich
bisher gemacht habe die zuschauer sehen
damals einen klaren gewinner doch nicht
zu unterschätzen die nachbetrachtung des
fernsehduells der sogenannte spin denen
die verschiedenen lager danach zu setzen
suchen merkels damaliger generalsekretär
ignoriert die zuschauer umfragen einfach
und sei recht behalten wir haben so
beurteile ich das ergebnis heute die
kanzlerin von deutschland gesehen
natürlich sehen nie alle 60 millionen
wahlberechtigte so eine tv-debatte aber
fast jeder bekommt drumherum irgendwas
davon mit sagt joachim koschnicke der
merkel zuletzt 2017 im wahlkampf beriet
wir haben die vorberichterstattung wir
haben dass das spektakel selber und dann
haben wir natürlich die die
nachberichterstattung wir sehen was im
social media parallel zu den tri allen
und im nachhinein passiert insofern das
ist immens und hat dementsprechend auch
einen hohen einfluss
2009 das duell steinmeier gegen merkel
die zuschauer küren in der blitzumfrage
danach den herausforderer zum sieger und
die spd hat ihren spin da sie als
steinmeier überhaupt keine frage doch
die wahl gewinnt wenig später wieder
genau angela merkel es gibt natürlich
menschen die wollen sozusagen mit beim
sieger seien aber andere menschen die
reagieren genau entgegengesetzt die
werden mit einer trotzreaktion wenn sie
sehen dass die partei die sie eigentlich
normalerweise präferieren zu stark
zurück fällt jede fernsehdebatte bleibt
eine wundertüte
sie hat ihre wirkung aber es ist schwer
zu berechnen für wen sie sich am ende
wirklich
ja und damit wie versprochen noch mal
zurück zu matthias fornoff und unseren
meinungsforschern matthias jetzt sind
die zahlen da oder müssten zumindest da
sein hoffentlich für die gesamte länge
des tri ace was hat sich geändert ja wir
haben die endgültigen zahlen gerade
reinbekommen und da sieht man schon dass
es noch ein paar veränderungen und
verschiebungen gegeben hat und wir
schauen uns gleich mal die erste grafik
an wer hat sich beim tvl am besten
geschlagen armin laschet sagen 20
prozent etwas mehr als nach der ersten
halbzeit olaf scholz 32% annalena
baerbock
26% und kein unterschied 21 prozent die
reihenfolge ist geblieben scholz vor
berbalk vor laschet jetzt schauen wir
mal nicht vergleichen sondern auf die
einzelnen kandidaten wie wie es das
erwartungsmanagement sozusagen gewesen
welche erwartungen sind erfüllt oder
übererfüllt worden bei armin laschet
sagen jetzt 35 prozent das war besser
als erwartet eine mehrheit von 53
prozent aber sagt so wie erwartet bei
olaf scholz ist das noch deutlicher 58
prozent hatten das in etwa so erwartet
und annalena baerbock das ist das
spannendste ergebnis vielleicht da sagt
eine mehrheit von 53 prozent sie hat
sich besser geschlagen als erwartet
wir gucken jetzt noch mal auf eine
andere grafik die wir noch nicht gezeigt
haben vorhin die zeigt die alters
staffelung und da sehen wir in der
jüngsten gruppe bei 18 bis 34 jahren da
sagt eine mehrheit von 52 prozent
annalena baerbock hat sich am besten
geschlagen bei den beiden anderen
gruppen 35 bis 59 und 60 plus liegt olaf
scholz vorn
und wir schauen noch auf die profile die
er oft erklären wie solche zahlen
zustande kommen wer war am
glaubwürdigsten olaf scholz mit einigem
abstand vor allen annalena baerbock und
mit noch größerem abstand vor armin
laschet wer war am sympathischsten da
hat annalena baerbock olaf scholz
überholt in der zweiten halbzeit 39 zu
28 prozent
armin laschet bleibt da deutlich hinten
mit 14 prozent und wer hat am meisten
sachverstand gezeigt nach wie vor ist
der olaf scholz vorne nicht mehr ganz so
deutlich wie vorhin 40 prozent sagen
dass aber armin laschet kommt eben auch
auf 21 frau berghoff 12 prozent da
zeigen sich also schon deutliche
unterschiede interessant interessant
auch die unterschiede zur ersten analyse
zur halbzeitanalyse sozusagen wirklich
interessante zahlen matthias ich habe
jetzt so im abschluss wenn man so will
eines langen polit abends hier im zdf
noch die frage zum schluss wen hätten
denn die menschen jetzt am liebsten als
bundeskanzlerin oder als bundeskanzler
ja das ist die frage aller fragen auch
wenn die leute natürlich wissen dass
kanzler oder kanzlerin nicht direkt
gewählt werden sondern über parteien
schauen wir uns das mal an wen hätten
sie am liebsten als bundeskanzler oder
kanzlerin die zuschauer vor dem tv trial
haben zu 19 prozent gesagt armin laschet
55% olaf scholz 19 prozent annalena
baerbock und nach dem tv trial sieht man
schon bewegungen olaf scholz der sehr
deutlich vorne war liegt immer noch
vorne hat aber punkte verloren armin
laschet hat aufgeholt relativ deutlich
und annalena baerbock etwas soviel zur
analyse und zu den daten von heute da
ist viel stoff dabei auch für die
nächsten tage lasse mich noch eins sagen
ach ist ja mehr müssen wir an dieser
stelle glaube ich noch einmal machen
diese zahlen sind repräsentiert
repräsentativ aber nur für die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer des tv elz
nicht für alle wahlberechtigten in
deutschland die eine einschränkung muss
noch sein haben wir vorhin ja schon
gemacht in der sendung aber gut dass das
nochmal wiederholt hass auf jeden fall
was dabei auch für die nächsten tage zur
diskussion hier in deutschland daher
gehe ich jede wette ein matthias vielen
dank gerne und jetzt bei uns hier etwas
komplett verrücktes träumen und das dann
wahr machen das war der lebensinhalt für
das künstlerpaar christo und jeanne
claude die beiden haben den berliner
reichstag verhüllt und inseln in florida
und nur ein letztes projekt ist nicht in
erfüllung gegangen bis heute denn jetzt
ist es soweit eineinhalb jahre nach
christus tod und 60 jahre nach beginn
der ersten planung der arc de triomphe
in paris verschwindet hinter 25.000
quadratmetern mit aluminium bedampft
polypropylen gewebe
an arbeit ist dabei
es schwebt eine andächtige ruhe über dem
monumentalen bau bahn für bahn verhüllen
mehr als 100 höhen arbeiter den arc de
triomphe ein lebenstraum des
künstlerpaars christo und jeanne-claude
dessen erfüllung sie jedoch nicht mehr
miterleben können heute zieht er paris
in den bann
horrillo war ich habe immer davon
geträumt dass zu sehen christo ist
einfach ein phänomen
im gegensatz zu dem was man denken würde
wäre das den triumphbogen auf man packt
ihn ein um ihn aufzuwerten das ist
paradox ich finde es unglaublich
es ist nicht sein erstes werk hier in
paris aber der triumphbogen ist auch ein
wenig das symbol der stadt nach dem
eiffelturm das ist genial
ein ästhetisches ein faires werk für
dessen bewilligung anders als bei
früheren aktionen kaum
überzeugungsarbeit nötig war christo ist
kult seit wochen laufen am bogen die
vorbereitungen auch deutsche firmen sind
beteiligt lieferten 25.000 quadratmeter
wiederverwertbares gewebe bauten die
unterkonstruktion größte herausforderung
der denkmalschutz flache stahlkäfig
schützen die ornamente möglichst
unversehrt soll das gemäuer bleiben
deshalb haben wir versucht ihr quasi
minimalinvasiv mit seilen und ganz wenig
stahlbau zu arbeiten und konnten so die
700 bohrungen die zur befestigung als
gerüst nötig sind auf 200 reduzieren die
idee hatte christo in den 1960 er später
skizzierte er die details in einem der
letzten interviews erklärte er dem zdf
wie in das bauwerk bereits beeindruckte
als er nach seinem kunststudium in paris
lebte
als ich zum ersten mal in paris ankam
hat mir jemand einen schirm rodelbahn
verschafft ein dienstmädchen zimmer in
der nähe der champs élysées ich hatte
den triumphbogen ständig vor augen er
war nur ein paar blocks entfernt von
meinem haus schon das ausrollen der
stoffbahnen gehörte für christo und
jeanne-claude zum kunstwerk jede
einzelne stoffe feierte wurde am
computer simuliert sein neffe vollendet
nun die pläne
leitet das projekt
wenn er jetzt hier an meiner stelle wäre
würde er aufgeregt um schreien und ich
hoffe am ende würde eher sagen es sieht
aus wie auf den zeichnungen dann haben
wir einen guten job gemacht
der triumphbogen werde ein lebendiges
objekt das sich im wind wiegt und dem
licht reflektiert hatte christo poetisch
angekündigt der künstler fehlt doch die
kunst wirkt weiter die verhüllung ist
sein vermächtnis
noch nie waren plastikplanen so poetisch
der triumphbogen atmet die aktion wirkt
also schon jetzt was die kommende woche
für uns bereithält neben sonne und wind
zeigt annegret oster der heute journal
ausblick
[Musik]
eine bundesweite aktionswoche soll der
ins stocken geratenen impfkampagne neuen
schwung geben ab montag wird es an
öffentlichen orten wie sportplätzen
fußgängerzonen und in geschäften viele
unkomplizierte impf gelegenheiten geben
nach ansicht des rk ii sind noch immer
deutlich zu wenige menschen geimpft um
einen dramatischen verlauf der vierten
welle zu verhindern
ebenfalls am montag werden die vereinten
nationen in genf eine humanitäre
geberkonferenz für afghanistan
ausrichten auch bundesaußenminister
heiko maas wird daran teilnehmen
nach einschätzung der un droht
afghanistan spätestens im kommenden
winter eine hungersnot schon jetzt haben
rund ein drittel der menschen im land zu
wenig zu essen
am dienstag will der jährlich
stattfindende tag der tropenwälder auf
die bedrohung des artenreichsten
naturraums der erde aufmerksam machen
allein in 2009 10 verschwanden laut
global forest lodge tropenwald flächen
von fast 12 millionen hektar
hauptursache ist deren umwandlung in
landwirtschaftliche nutzflächen
am mittwoch wird eu kommissionspräsident
in ursula von der leyen ihrer jährlichen
rede zur lage der union halten neben
einer bilanz des vergangenen jahres wird
es auch um die dringendsten künftigen
herausforderungen der europäischen union
gehen wie zb den klimawandel die korona
pandemie und den schutz der demokratie
und das wetter in der neuen woche ist
zunächst spätsommerlich schön ab
dienstag wird es wechselhaft
morgen ist es nur im norden bewölkt aber
es bleibt trocken im süden scheint nach
nebel die sonne in den alpen einzelne
schauer 27 grad am oberrhein und 18 grad
an den küsten am dienstag im westen
schauer und gewitter bis donnerstag
zieht ein regengebiet von west nach ost
täglich wird es etwas kühler am
donnerstag nur noch 18 bis 22 grad und
mit diesen wechselhaften aussichten geht
ein langer spannender polit abend im zdf
zu ende morgen freuen sich hier marietta
slomka und hans wolf auf sie aktuell
informiert sind sie immer auf zeit
erfreute und später hier gegen 0.50 vom
gesamten sonntags team und uns zweien
hier danke fürs zuschauen und ihnen
allen ein sehr angenehmer haben
[Musik]